it's clear that the past set of efforts
have not succeeded I am a believer in
diplomacy and I am open to new methods
of trying to accomplish the the
consistent objective that we have a full
denuclearization I think the question is
are we walking in prepared are we
walking in with our allies behind us are
we in a position to understand that one
meeting it's not going to be one and
done this is the start of a serious
negotiating process former National
Security Advisor Susan Rice talking
about this upcoming summit between
President Trump and Kim jong-un both
leaders traveling a long distance
obviously coming from Canada the g7
summit the president did but Washington
DC to Singapore here and Pyongyang this
is the farthest that Kim jong-un has
traveled since taking power in 2011 no
sitting president has met with a leader
as far as we know a North Korean leader
or spoken to one on the phone as far as
we know what about the expectations here
and what are the possibilities let's
bring in our panel from DC Molly
Hemingway senior editor at The
Federalist Susan page Washington bureau
chief at USA Today and Tom Rogan
commentary writer for the Washington
Examiner Tom I think that there has been
a setting of expectations a little bit
of saying this could be the first of
several summits what are your thoughts
heading into Tuesday well the first
thing I think that is clear now that
this progressive step process that the
North Koreans in particular wanted will
be the case but I think on the part of
the Trump administration especially push
this narrative by Secretary of State
Mike Pompeo both outside and behind the
scenes the need to have some kind of
tangible product come of this first
summit beyond just shaking hands we've
made friends a couple of tweets and I
think what that will be will be some
kind of limited inspections presence
from the IAEA in North Korea within a
couple of weeks maybe three weeks
following the summit but again I think
the critical factor will be how
intrusive is that does it involve snap
inspections and I think again the
president Trump will need a deliverable
that he can say we'll look there's
something tans
here which means this process must go on
yeah Susan well you know I think the
issue is not only what the North Koreans
agree to do but what the u.s. gives up
to achieve some kind of deliverable
something so president Trump can say
it's a success you know we've already
given up quite a bit we've given this
meeting which the North Koreans wanted
we're going to have the picture which
the North Koreans have wanted of the two
leaders shaking hands as equals so I
think one concern that some have is that
the United States not give more ground
on things without the without the North
Koreans taking tangible steps that
actually lead to a reduction of the
nuclear threat one thing malee that the
president said on Friday before leaving
was that he really wants Congress in
this this whole thing take a listen
I would only do a deal if I get it
through Congress I wouldn't do like
Obama did and fortunately he wasn't able
to get it through he you know he tried
to get it through the Iran deal he tried
to get it through Congress failed so he
just did it without which is why I was
able to break it up so easy so I mean in
adding to the challenges here the
challenge to get to heard the cats in
Congress to get an actual treaty through
well it's absolutely true that President
Obama's failure to seal his Iran deal
with congressional approval sealed the
fate of that deal it's very easy to
change things if you don't have treaties
ratified by the Senate
it is important with something as
important as a deal with North Korea
that the Senate be on board and that the
American people be on board understand
fully what we are giving in exchange for
denuclearization if that is what is on
the if that is what is on the table
and it is absolutely important that we
get some indication right away that
North Korea is serious they have a long
history of promising grandiose things
and failing to failing to comply with
what they have promised after they get
the goods from other countries I don't
think the Americans are interested in
that kind of agreement this time around
yeah and you know you ask Americans
about n we took a poll a Fox News poll
recently and you asked them about the
possibilities will new North Korea ever
give up its nuclear weapons 28 percent
say now yes 60 percent say no and you
can see kind of the the change from
March of 2018 the other question was who
would get the better deal and most
people now 40 percent say Donald Trump
you get the better deal kim jong than
the 30 percent we don't know what we
don't know about behind the scenes in
these negotiations tom but the first
meeting is going to be with the two
leaders and just translators nobody else
yes exactly and you know apart from the
tensions between the North Korean and
Security Service and the Secret Service
you know I think the baseline here will
be President Trump testing Kim jong-un
as to what he can get out of it and and
the critical factor as well it's not
just the summit and what follows it
but how external actors react to it as
well specifically the Chinese and the
Russians we already see someone I
thought - who's been in North Korea
recently mentioned that the actual flow
of goods across that border has
significantly up ticked as this summit
has progressed it - its arrival and and
so for president Trump to retain that
pressure alongside little concessions
and little gains will be a difficult
balancing act because of course if the
Chinese are able to double down their
support for Kim Jong on his incentive to
just play this out and behind the scenes
develop the warhead vehicle booker t so
there are a lot of moving parts so I
think the fortunate thing is Mike Pompeo
is the lead CIA director he kind of are
the key he has the president's trust and
he also has an understanding of what is
going on here you know Susan I have
heard anecdotally that Kim jong-un has
expressed a need and a want for
investments in this country in North
Korea and even hotels along the
coastline and has kind of mused about
that in meetings the question is is
getting from one point to the to the
next having a McDonald's in downtown
that would be something perhaps he'd be
interested in well I think we're
counting on that I think that when we
when you hear President Trump talk about
why North Korea may be willing to give
up its nukes and there's a lot of
skepticism about that it's because it
could draw the kind of investment and
development that would make things
better for their people you know Molly
made a made a good point which is that
North Korea has a history of reneging on
the deals that they've made since 1994 I
wonder if the United States is going to
face more questions than usual this time
around because the Iran deal was reached
by the previous administration that is
now unraveling and even because of the
of the summit of the g7 summit the sense
that the United States signed on to a
communique and after getting being
unhappy about a news conference then
unsigned the communique and I'd be
curious to see if that raises any
questions across the table about whether
they can count on the United States to
live up to a deal that's reached well as
I mentioned with the previous group here
in Singapore Molly I mean that sense two
signals one maybe he's not going to
follow through on some communique but
two he'd get up from the table if it's
not the deal and listens to some leaders
say something that he doesn't like
well first off our Constitution provides
a means for other countries to feel
confident in how we have come to a
decision and that does involve
ratification by the Senate and that is a
norm that should not have been breached
by previous administrations and it's
something that really works well and
it's already in our system it is also
true that Donald Trump behaves in a very
unprecedented manner he does not seem to
think that the global order as
orchestrated by elites for the past
several decades is necessarily good we
see in North Korea it has not worked out
well for many decades that crosses party
lines and many administrations
so he is looking to do something
different that is definitely not
necessarily bad when it comes to
denuclearization of the Korean Peninsula